it's my right honorable friendís alarmed
as I am that Alex Salmond is plan to
impose a series of demands on the UK
government and will he confirm he will
have nothing to do with such demands why
I think my honourable friend makes a
very important point as far as I can see
Alex Salmond has taken the entire labour
party hostage and today and today we
have got the ransom note and the ransom
note is very clear it says higher
borrowing it says uncontrolled
immigration unfettered welfare higher
taxes and weaker defence that is what is
being demanded and the British people
have only one way of saying no to this
appalling hostage situation and that is
to vote conservative on Minnesota